vladimir poutine a passé une partie de
sa journée à gérer la crise économique
dans laquelle se trouve son pays suite
aux sanctions décidées par les
occidentaux il a tenu une réunion
exceptionnelle avec différents acteurs
de l'économie russe ou de la finance
russe et notamment le directeur de la
banque centrale ou encore son premier
ministre en introduction il a indiqué
qu'ils étaient là pour répondre aux
sanctions décidées par je cite lempire
des mensonges un décret a été signé à la
suite de cette réunion avec trois
mesures exceptionnelles et notamment
l'interdiction pour les citoyens russes
de transférer leurs devises étrangères à
l'étranger ou encore et bien
l'interdiction d'obtenir des prêts en
devises et enfin l'obligation pour les
entreprises exportatrices russe de
vendre 80 % de leur devise un peu plus
tôt dans la journée c'est la banque
centrale russe qui avait pris une mesure
exceptionnelle en réhaussant son taux
directeur de 9 5% à 20% tout cela se
passe dans un moment de tension de
pression sur le kremlin notamment de la
part des oligarques russes pourtant
réputé proche de poutine qui exigeait
une réponse forte à cette crise pour
répondre à cette crise économique en
tout cas tout cela plonge la russie et
donc les citoyens russes dans une longue
période d'incertitude